[Musique]
j'ai toujours moins une pensée pour tous
ces jeunes qui nous ont qui nous ont
quittés que ce soit drillet louis où
nicolas moi je n'oublierai jamais parce
qu'ils sont morts sur un terrain de
rugby
[Musique]
les autres partis sont plus en plus
directe dur mais c'est normal on aurait
souhaité
[Musique]
une
comme c'est une blessure minime
la tendance a longtemps parlé c'est une
sur ta vie ta vidéo où on va dire chez
ma tête j'en ferais sortir c'est qu'on
ait jamais les miqo'tes on dirait une
chochotte
[Musique]
une fois que ces lésions sont créés il
va falloir que le cerveau les réparer ça
ça va prendre du temps
[Musique]
dans la glacière je commence je sentais
pas bien et je commençais vomi dans le
vestiaire le doigt qui m'a quand même
laisser rentrer sur le terrain profite
ni le macho
[Musique]
ceux qui viennent pour faire mal
pak allemand avec les épaules et cetera
moi je suis pour les exclure et les
punir il faut punir sévèrement
en commission lundi aux professionnels
on se rend compte parce qu'il ya la télé
mais un niveau amateur il y en a bien
plus ils sont moins pris en charge si on
prône plus à en ruby ed ce qu'yves de
passe et d'évitement en fait puisque le
contact et de regroupement peut-être
qu'effectivement on pourrait arriver à
une solution un peu plus viable au
niveau des commotions et des blessures
[Musique]